bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission que vous pourrez regarder
autour d'un vin chaud en train du ski
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons vous
parler des plans sociaux duo qu'ovide
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
après avoir affronté une première puis
une deuxième vague de kovy 19 le pays
va-t-il devoir faire face à une vague de
licenciements dans cette émission on va
aujourd'hui s'intéresser aux victimes
économiques de la crise sanitaire par
combien de plans sociaux la france est
elle menacée combien d'emplois sont en
danger
le grenat virus est il vraiment dans
tous les cas le coupable
on va en parler dans ce numéro de ses
cachets pour cela en deuxième partie
nous serons en liaison avec laurent
mauduit écrivain journaliste spécialisé
dans les affaires économiques politiques
et sociales et co-fondateur de mediapart
plus de 35000 exactement 35 1674 c'est
le nombre de destructions de postes
annoncées depuis septembre dernier selon
une étude trendeo pour le monde
industries manufacturières arts et
spectacles immobilier de nombreux
secteurs sont touchés
faut-il pour autant tout mettre sur le
dos du corona virus éléments de réponse
avec le tiroir cajd entraînerait sas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est une vraie hécatombe depuis nos
premiers confinement la france fait face
à des licenciements en pagaille des
plans sociaux chez danone ibm total sans
compter ceux des plus petites
entreprises toutes les régions de france
sont touchées dans de très nombreux
secteurs mediapart des nombreux près de
75 mille emplois perdus au 2 décembre
dans plus de 300 entreprises selon le
magazine alternatives économiques c'est
carrément sept cent mille emplois
disparus depuis mars
mais bon on le sait tout ça c'est la
faute du coc vite pas besoin de
s'épancher sur la question voilà merci
de m'avoir écouté reid au générique de
ce trou enfin y'a peut-être pas que
locaux vides non plus n'ont pourrait-on
soupçonner un effet d'aubaine ou un as
du 10 servie sur un plateau si vous
préférez mêmes et qu'ils avaient bornes
la ministre du travail à quelques
soupçons déclarant que des plans sociaux
en cette période poser question et
appelant notamment à la responsabilité
des grands groupes du cac 40
faut dire qu'avec les moyens mis sur la
table pour sauver les entreprises de la
crise pas le gouvernement un peu
l'impression d'être pris pour lapins de
six semaines
des milliards d'euros il attendait au
moins que les entreprises préservent
leurs salariés et fasse passer l'emploi
avant la rentabilité
c'est décidément mal connaître les
moustiques danone par exemple
'l'annonce 2000 suppressions d'emplois
dans le monde
mais maintient ses dividendes versés à
1,5 milliard d'euros ou total 1500
départs et 6 milliards d'euros sur
l'exercice de 2019 aux actionnaires de
là à penser qu'ils auraient favorisé les
actionnaires aux salariés et profiter du
coc vite pour mener à bien quelques
restructurations bien senti
prévue de longue date il n'y a qu'un pas
mais ce n'est pas moi qui ne franchirait
olivier on l'a vu il ya plusieurs nombre
annoncé sur les destructions d'emploi il
y en aura d'autres on se souvient
d'ailleurs à des mots du ministre de
l'économie à bruno lemaire chez nos
confrères d'europe 1 nous nous attendons
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent un nombre de licenciements
élevée et à des faillites alors at on
atteint le pic est il trop tard pour
arrêter l'hémorragie beaucoup trop tard
et puis vous savez que en effet beaucoup
d des plans sociaux étaient déjà prévus
depuis longtemps et le que vides ne sert
jusque de prétexte c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup plus facile de lui mettre ça
sur le dos on savait très bien par
exemple que dans les banques il allait
fermer les agences bancaires et donc que
c'était prévu depuis longtemps de
licencier simplement il fallait il
fallait un prétexte parce que c'est pas
facile de licencier en france donc là
c'est le prétexte tout trouvé et tous
rêvé on met ça sur le dos du coc vide et
on ferme les agences en accéléré donc
évidemment beaucoup de licenciements à
venir
et puis il ya beaucoup de licenciements
qu'on ne comptabilise pas pourquoi tout
simplement parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'indépendants qui n'avaient pas les
moyens de se payer une assurance chômage
et qui vont sortir des radars complet et
donc vous ne les comptabilise ray pas
dans les chômeurs pourquoi parce qu'ils
y ont pas droit et donc ils passeront en
dessous en dessous du radar
ça vous l'avez aux états unis ça vous
l'avez en france et partout ailleurs
pourquoi parce que ces dernières années
on a vous savez on se
on se plaisait à dire que le/la
l'économie subit risée et donc des
salariés avant se retrouver
entrepreneurs et entrepreneurs qui
n'avait évidemment pas le droit au
chômage parce qu'ils étaient bien
incapables de payer une assurance
chômage prix donc voilà
le conte ne sait absolument pas en fait
exactement combien de gens vont aller au
chômage ou sortir je vous dis
complètement du jeu et tomber dans la
pauvreté il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on annonce en chiffres
simplement comptabiliser des annonces
des grandes sociétés
il faut pas oublier aussi que quand une
société du cac 40
annonce des licenciements eh bien vous
avez aussi tous les fournisseurs qui
sont des petits petites entreprises et
qui vont subir et qui donc vous dans un
deuxième temps vont licencier
donc en fait les licenciements ça va
c'est pas c'est pas les licenciements
d'aujourd'hui qui vont être très
importants il va y avoir une flambée du
chômage au premier trimestre 2001 21
parce que jusqu'à présent vous aviez
toutes les mesures qui avaient été mises
en place comme le chômage partiel et
serra qui éviter de mettre les gens au
chômage définitif et une fois ces
mesures terminée eh bien les sociétés
vont qu'ils ne vont pas ouvrir comme les
restaurants comme les stations de ski
puisqu'il paraît que c'est un haut lieu
de clusters comme les stations de ski et
bien tout ça vont mettre des gens au
chômage dès la rentrée et dès que les
mesures ponctuelles
à moins que s'éternisent dans le temps
et que dans dix ans on est encore du
chômage partiel mais à ce moment là il
faudra drôlement faire tourner la
planche à billets pour que ça fonctionne
merci olivier on passe tout de suite à
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec laurent mauduit bonjour vous êtes
écrivain journaliste co fondateur de
mediapart et vous êtes spécialisé dans
les affaires économiques politiques et
sociales bienvenue dans ces caches
merci bonjour à l'origine il n'y a pas
de vague massive de licenciements en
france le chômage partiel fonctionne
avait assuré l'ex-ministre du travail
muriel pénicaud dans une interview au
parisien
fin avril aujourd'hui selon les chiffres
donnés par mediapart 74200 58 emplois
sont condamnés ou menacés cela concerne
3 217 entreprises dans le 84 département
le monde de son côté avance plus de
35000 destructions de postes laurent
mauduit peut-on parler aujourd'hui de
vague massive de licenciement 2020 annus
horribilis pour l'emploi
bah écoutez tous les indicateurs sont
l'âge il ya une cascade c'est une
déferlante il ya d'abord ce qu'on voit
les plans improprement appelée de
sauvegarde de l'emploi qui sont faites
de destruction de l'emploi airbus
n'obtient celio auchan danone total
vallourec bref puis à ce qu'on ne voit
pas par ailleurs est-ce qu'on ne
comptabilise pas dans les plans je vous
rappelle que à cause de ce capitalisme
très financiarisé il ya eu précarité de
l'emploi je donne juste un exemple
l'automobile un emploi sur deux est en
intérim et donc la fin des missions
d'intérim donc lancé en chômage se fait
de manière quasi invisible est donc le
véritable indicateur maintenant des
souffrances sociales induites par cette
déferlante c'est beaucoup moins les
statistiques du chômage qu'en fait que
maintenant le taux de pauvreté et vous
avez entendu les alertes des
associations humanitaires à tchô nous
allons nous approcher cette année sans
doute de la barre fatidique des 10
millions de chômeurs a donc je pense
qu'il faut avoir un regard très sévère
sur la politique conduite par ce
gouvernement parce que me semble-t-il
c'est lui et sans doute qu'ils
reviendront nous qui porte la
responsabilité de ce comportement des
entreprises l'emploi est la seule
variable d'ajustement
olivier une réaction on s'attendait à ce
que l économie souffre à cause de cette
crise sanitaire l'exécutif avait prévenu
pour autant est-ce qu'on a sous-estimé
l'ampleur des dégâts vous savez c'est le
chiffre du chômage et tout
jour sous-estimé toujours ça fait ça
fait des années que c'est comme ça
pourquoi parce que on vous donne
toujours la même catégorie de chômeurs
c'est à dire le chômage de catégorie a
et on oublie évidemment le reste on
oublie les gens qui sortent des
statistiques on oublie des gens qui ont
des en pro d emplois précaires comme le
disait notre invité on oublie tout ça et
tout ça en fait si vous le si vous le
cumul et si vous refaites les
statistiques si vous retravaillé dessus
vous apercevez que le taux de chômage a
toujours été largement supérieurs alors
après certains vont ticket en disant ah
ben non mais c'est pas du chômage
oui d'accord mais enfin c'est celui qui
travaille une heure par semaine excusez
moi mais c'est quand même du chômage
donc ça veut dire que vous avez des
chiffres qui sont bien supérieures déjà
depuis le départ avant que vides qui
sont bien supérieurs à ce qui était
annoncé
là dessus vous arrivez avec le co vide
que vie qui arrive sur une économie qui
est déjà exsangue et en effet vous avez
ce ce jeu malsain d'une dune d'un état
qui donne des milliards à des
entreprises et qu'ils soient des
graisses derrière soi
en même temps d'ailleurs souvent paient
des dividendes énormes
et puis on profite quelquefois aussi
pour racheter leurs propres titres ce
qui est l'aberration suprême mais ça
fait monter les titres en attendant et
donc les actionnaires sont contents et
les dirigeants qui sont souvent payés en
stock options saute aussi content et
voilà et c'est tout ce qui importe mais
on a on a vraiment un problème de
chômage et qui va qui va être explosif
n'en doutez pas un seul instant
aujourd'hui la gestion de la crise c'est
pas la crise sanitaire qui est un
problème c'est la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire et la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire qui a été fait suse et moi par
des bras cassés depuis depuis le début
de cette histoire c'est à dire depuis le
début 2020 et bien aujourd'hui rajoute
une catastrophe en amplifiant de
beaucoup cette crise qui je voulais dit
n'a jamais été réglé depuis 2008 et donc
la poussière non seulement ressort du
tapis de sous le tapis mais en plus on
en rajoute alors leur mode vie ces
destructions de postes aurait-elle pu
être évitée par exemple si l'on avait
conditionner les aides mises en place
par le gouvernement
c'est l'une des questions que l'on peut
légitimement posée parce que tout de
même pesons le compte on offre une aide
actuellement historique un sou à
hollande à travers d'abord lé d'abord le
cic eu 43 milliards d'euros puis ensuite
on l'a pérennise en baisse de charge
dans le pacte de responsabilité et
macron poursuit cette politique
l'accentuer
dans le cadre du plan de relance sur les
100 milliards y en a 20 qui vaut aux
entreprises et à chaque fois cet argent
est donné sans conditions sans
contrepartie donc dès 2014 ya des débats
mais ce qu'il faudrait au moins posé des
conditions en termes d'emploi gier le
l'argent public doit avoir une
contrepartie
sinon ça crée des effets d'aubaine or on
sait à cause des études économiques qui
ont été faites notamment sur le pack de
responsabilité sur les 43 milliards
d'euros que ça n'a quasiment pas créé
d'emplois on a arrosé du sable et donc
l'aspect stupéfiants je trouve est
politiquement très choquant de ce que
l'on vit c'est que donc des entreprises
dont était gorgé d'être public et ça n'a
créé que des effets d'aubaine et donc
observer maintenant ce à quoi on assiste
effectivement on continue des versements
de dividendes considérable aux
actionnaires et il ya même des
entreprises moi je les documenter de
manière méticuleuse sur mediapart qui
profitent du chômage partiel
en clair les salaires sont payés par
l'état et en même temps il ya des
versements de dividendes déjà des
entreprises comme publicis qui est au
cac 40
des entreprises comme capgemini com qui
vendent y vivent indiqué contrôlée par
monsieur vincent bolloré et l'état ne
dira rien ayant un aspect moralement
éthiquement très choquant de penser que
par exemple l'actionnaire principal de
publicis madame elisabeth badinter a
empoché home juin dernier plus de 19
millions d'euros de dividendes et en
même temps c'est l'état qui paie les
salaires des employés de publicis ce
champs elysées donc on est dans un
capitalisme qui a profondément modifié
ses règles de gouvernance on est sorti
il ya longtemps du capitalisme rhénan
pour entre entrer dans un capitalisme
d'actionnaires ce qui profite dans une
crise il ya toujours ceux qui trinquent
et ceux qui en profitent
là on voit bien que les actionnaires
sont totalement épargnée et la seule
variable d'ajustement et l'état devaient
rien si l'emploi sans cela que c'est
très très grave puisque l'on vit alors
on va revenir sur les licenciements dans
les grands groupes mais d'abord on va
marquer une courte pause
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez aujourd'hui nous sommes en
liaison avec laurent mauduit journaliste
co fondateur de mediapart spécialisé
dans les affaires économiques politiques
et sociales
olivier juste avant la pub
laurent mauduit a parlé d'un effet
d'aubaine alors justement selon le
ministère du travail 65 1777 rupture de
contrat sont envisagées dans le cadre de
619 pse c'est plus de deux fois plus
qu'en 2019 lancer des procédures
sociales d'une telle ampleur en pleine
période de crise sanitaire pose question
ce sont là les mots a dit mme de la
ministre du travail lisa bête bornes
devant les parlementaires le 24 novembre
dernier
olivier la crise sanitaire n'est pas la
seule responsable
ah non la crise sanitaire n'est pas la
ils sont les politiques qui met depuis
des années les politiques qui n'ont
jamais rien compris à l'économie comme
monsieur bruno le maire pense que tout
se règle à coups de chacun mais ça coûte
chèque sans contrepartie mais comme les
banques centrales d'ailleurs regardez ce
que ce qu'ils font depuis le début les
banques centrales arrosent les marchés
financiers pour que les sociétés
enfin le cours des sociétés n'arrête pas
de monter qu'elle soit que d'ailleurs
que ce soit des sociétés qui fasse du
résultat ou pas la bourse s'en fiche
complètement et continue à les faire
grimper aujourd'hui vous avez exemple
tuer le musk avec tesla qui vaut plus de
500 milliards de capitalisation alors
qui vend 300 mille voitures bon donc
quand on en est là si vous voulez vous
avez des banques centrales qui arrose
pour faire monter les marchés et qui se
fiche complètement de ce qui se passe
dans l'économie réelle et vous avez des
politiques qui se fichent aussi
apparemment en tout cas ou alors ils
prennent vraiment des mesures et ils
font semblant plutôt d'être étonné
derrière que ça ne fonctionne pas
en hand et en permettant à des
entreprises de s'endetter en permettant
à des entreprises survivent
alors ce sont des entreprises zombies ce
qui fait couler les autres d'ailleurs ce
qui fait couler celle qu'ils ne sont pas
en bis et et tout ça et gérait je vous
dis fin de la pire des façons depuis des
années ça n'est pas récent ça n'est pas
ça n'est pas venu simplement avec la
crise du que vides
ça fait combien d'années que on donne
quelquefois à des entreprises de
l'argent directement pour qu'elles ne
licencient pas ou pour qu'elle vienne
s'installer chez nous et où qu'elle
rachète une autre entreprise et qu'elle
licencie derrière et qu'on fait semblant
de d'en être vraiment choqué étonné en
dix ans mais je comprends pas on leur a
donné des sous et puis ils font pas ce
qu'on leur demande a évidemment fin ça
fait des années que ça dure c'est pas
nouveau il n'y a rien de nouveau sous le
soleil
la seule chose c'est que là maintenant
c'est tellement gros que ça se voit donc
les gens réagissent mais ça a toujours
été comme ça toujours laurent mauduit un
mot sur ses appuis dit verrier
secrétaire général de force ouvrière il
s'exprimait sur france info au sujet des
licenciements à venir chez danone il est
inacceptable que le souci premier soin
de rassurer les actionnaires quand les
salariés sont inquiets quand les
entreprises ont bénéficié dette publique
avec l'activité partielle de longue
durée à laquelle a pu faire appel danone
nous l'avions dit il ne faut pas que
l'on autorise le versement de dividendes
lorsqu'une entreprise touchent des aides
de l'état
ce serait une solution cela ou deux
selon vous pour préserver l'emploi
les préposés les conditions c'est la
moindre des choses quand il en va
d'argent public et c'est vrai que une
fois qu'on a fait ces constats
macroéconomique il faut rentrer dans le
détail parce qu'il ya plein de plans
sociaux entreprise par entreprise qui
invite à des réflexions tout de même
parfois assez stupéfiant donc un oeil à
danone danone l'entreprise présenté
pendant des lustres en entreprise
citoyenne avec le fondateur antoine
riboud qui était un patron de gauche
actionnaire de libération
bon quand on les voit aujourd'hui
distribués
le montant du dividende qu'ils ont
annoncés et qui en même temps ils
profitent de l'argent public géré un
aspect très choquant intégré cinq
milliards là les dividendes
c'est ça il faut dire total penser que
total d'israël qui fait des bénéfices
records année après année engage un plan
de sauvegarde de l'emploi
voilà aimé dans la liste il faut parler
aussi de renault rno dont l'actionnaire
principal même s'il est faible c'est
l'état 15% à garder 15% et que renault
engage un plan de restructuration des
usines de flins les bras vous en tombent
mais regarde ensuite dans le détail par
exemple des mesures d'investissement
prises par la banque publique
d'investissement parfois les bras vous
en tombent
vous savez l'une des dernières mesures
qu'a pris la bpi la bpi vous savez cette
bête est la banque un peu rooseveltienne
qui sortent l'économie de la finance
dans les années à mesure plan
d'investissement de 50 millions d'euros
au profit de qui au profit de monsieur
xavier niel jarnet tu manges qu'elle
dans quel monde vit-on
on n'est pas essayé ma petite nuance e
minime avec monsieur la marche on n'est
pas face à des politiques qui ne
connaissent rien il ya une petite
oligarchie politico financières dont
maquereau et le porte étendard qui vit
en consanguinité
c'est le propre du capitalisme français
capitalisme consanguins et monsieur m'a
croate est toujours resté ce qu'il était
dans le passé un banquier d'affaires et
gère cette crise au profit de ce
capitalisme d'actionnaires a donc voilà
autrefois le vieux capitalisme rhénan il
y avait une sorte de partage entre le
capital et le travail
là on est arrivé vous savez le vieux
principe de marx le capital ou à toute
chose dans les eaux glacées du calcul
égoïste et bien voilà c'est ce qu'on dit
aujourd'hui oui bien des réactions
non mais je suis je ne suis pas du tout
dupe je dis qu une grande partie sont en
tout cas n'ont pas les compétences qu'on
leur prête et que souvent ils sont
tellement incompétents que ça frise la
bêtise mais mais d'un autre côté je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec vous sur le
fait que c'est pas perdu pour tout le
monde qu'ils le font aussi
avec avec des idées derrière la tête
quand on voit de toute façon pu par
exemple les patrons des banques c'est
qui c'est des gens qui viennent du
trésor donc ils ont fait leurs études
avec les politiques et souvent
d'ailleurs il retourne à la politique
après avoir fait un petit tour dans des
dans des entreprises comme ça à chaud
alors je peux vous convions que
évidemment évidemment vous avez des vous
avez des des liens et vous avez des
idées derrière la tête quand on donne de
l'argent et qu'on sait très bien
ils le savent cl ça fait des années donc
ils le savent ils savent très bien que
il n'y aura pas de contrepartie sauf
peut-être des gens mise au chômage donc
voilà on n'est pas personne n'est dupe
là dessus alors ils versent leurs
petites larmes parce que ça fait ça fait
quand même bien mais ils savent très
bien depuis le début
à quoi cet argent va être utilisé ils
sont pas totalement idiot
le roman devient voulien agir non
c'était une remarque de passer la marche
mais il faisait penser
vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit il ya à
peine une semaine
le gouverneur de la banque de france il
a fait un discours pour inviter les
banques françaises à reprendre le
versement des dividendes
bon il faut savoir qui est gouverneur de
la banque de france s'est il a passé 13
ans comme cadre dirigeant de bnp paribas
il est lié à ce monde
la banque privée le voilà maintenant qui
revient dans la sphère publique et qui
défend ses anciens patrons
c'est un peu un symbole de ce que l'on
vit un ce que je pointais cette
oligarchie politico financières essuie
glaces qui est tantôt du côté l'intérêt
général tantôt du côté des intérêts
privés qui défend toujours les intérêts
privés
c'est pour ça qu'on traverse si mal
cette crise c'est que il faudrait que
dans cette crise chacun supporte sa peur
il n'y a aucune raison que ce soit
seulement les salariés qui paie les pots
cassés de cette crise et que les
actionnaires eux soient totalement
protégés protéger il faudrait donc le
vrai débat que suscite cette crise et ne
faut-il pas et regardez à quel point ce
débat a été portée aux états unis
pendant le débat des primaires notamment
au sein du parti démocrate
ne faudrait-il pas prendre des mesures
énergiques pour que chacun paie sa part
pour que les actionnaires j'étais avec
avec le fameux un contrat social de la
loi pacte ben voilà cette veste est
enfin oui sans roque sarrybiens le débat
qui aux états unis pendant là elle
pendant les primaires le débat a été
relancé ne fera t-il pas à l'impôt sur
le revenu qui monte jusqu'à 80 ou 90%
tel qu'on l'a connu au début des années
80 il ya eu a donc un très fort débat
sur la fiscalité en france il ya eu des
mesures cache-sexe autour de la loi
pâques pour que les entreprises et des
missions citoyennes
ça fait entre nous ça fait doucement
rire les mesures étaient pas énergie du
tout mais même ces mesures cosmétiques
n'ont pas été respectées puisque
l'entreprise symbole de la loi pape qui
était à nod maintenant viole ses
engagements merci beaucoup à laurent
mauduit d'avoir été parmi nous dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
écrivain journaliste spécialisé dans les
affaires économiques politiques et
sociales et co-fondateur de mediapart
olivier on passe aux questions cash
et on commence tout de suite avec la
question de ilan w les marchés étant
irrationnel et imprévisible
comment sécuriser utilement quelques
dizaines de milliers d'euros dans la
mesure où les valeurs refuge comme
l'immobilier les métaux sont au plus
haut si ce n'est aux prêts des banques
de dépôt à écouter ou on en a parlé les
banques de dépôt sont absolument pas sur
l'immobilier si vous avez seulement
quelques dizaines de milliers d'euros
à part la ferme complètement en ruines
sur le plateau du larzac je vois pas
bien et les métaux ont beau être au plus
haut mais avec ce qui se passe dans les
banques centrales aujourd'hui avec les
banques centrales qui ne peuvent plus je
vous rappelle revenir en arrière et qui
sont bien obligés de continuer à
imprimer des billets longue vie aux
métaux que ce soit hors que ce soit
platine que ce soit argent métal vous
pouvez encore aller dessus même si ça a
beaucoup monté
deuxième question elle est signée à
nicolas imbert bonsoir olivier que
pensez vous de la mise en place d'une
flat tax à 15% pour tous les revenus en
france il en serait de même pour liesse
à rétablir est de les quitter et
renforcerait l'investissement par
l'épargné mais écoutez je doute que ce
soit le sujet actuellement qu'ils soient
discutés à bercy je vous rappelle que
nous nous nous sommes endettés
au delà de tout de tout
raison et donc la dette est un nabot
décalé vous allez plutôt avoir des
impôts qui vont monter d'autant plus que
jamais l'état ne se remet en question et
l'état ne se pose la question de savoir
comment dépenser moins et dépenser mieux
question à présent en rapport avec notre
précédente émission consacrée au veto de
la hongrie au plan de relance européen
elle est signée stéphane hernandez
pensez vous que tout ceci mènera à
l'éclatement de la zone euro dans les
mois à venir
sinon comment les pays vont ils faire
face aux dépenses et relancer leur
économie
c'est une c'est une question qui
évidemment quand on voit les
dysfonctionnements de l'euro depuis le
début de cette histoire revient revient
sur le devant de la scène alors
maintenant est-ce que ça va être dans
les prochains mois ou dans les prochain
semestre
je n'ai pas de boule de cristal merci
olivier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission en attendant me poser toutes
vos questions à olivier sur les réseaux
sociaux ou en commentaire des vidéos
rendez-vous aussi sur rt france point tv
pour redécouvrir les précédents c'est
cash
olivier on se quitte avec votre dernier
mot écoutez je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine et en attendant je vais aller
chausser les skis